[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 176 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm your host Michelle Casbon
and I'm here with my colleague
Mark Mirchandani.
Hello, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hello, Michelle, you
know all this time I've been
saying Casbin as opposed
to Casbon.
MICHELLE CASBON: There are
many pronunciations of the name
and I am not very
particular about it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
OK, that's good.
I'll have to come up
with some other ones
and then see which
ones I could test.
And then eventually
you'll be like,
no, it needs to be Casbon.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
I mean, eventually
you'll hit a spot
where I'll be like,
OK, no, it's
definitely not that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Cash--
MICHELLE CASBON: But
otherwise, you can be flexible.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Cashbun-- no too much.
MICHELLE CASBON:
That's probably not it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
All right, I've
nailed this entire thing
in just 20 seconds.
Good to know.
MICHELLE CASBON:
All right, so who
do you have on the show today?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So today
we're talking with Di Dang.
She is a design advocate, which
is also a very fancy title.
And she works inside of
Google to kind of publish out
a guidebook on some of
the interactions driving
the human centered AI movement
right now, talking about
like what is the responsible
way to build an AI system, what
are the things that
you should kind of take
into consideration.
We had a really, really great
chat about what went into that
and how are people
using this guidebook.
But before we get into
that, we should probably
talk about the cool
thing of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON:
Oh, like usual, we
have a few cool things
of the week, right?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Many, many cool things.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, so the
theme for our first cool thing
is open source.
This is something that GCP
just strongly believes in.
You can see that
with TensorFlow,
with Go, Kubernetes, an even
Kubeflow, the project that I've
been involved in.
And we recently announced
some big partnerships
with leading open source
providers for data management
and analytics.
And these are people like
Confluent, Data Stacks,
Elastic, Influx Data, MongoDB,
Neo4j, and Redis Labs.
Now that's a really long
list of really big players
in the open source space.
And what that means is
that you can look forward
to seeing managed services
from these providers.
And that's really great,
because it means that it's
tightly integrated into GCP.
So instead of having to roll
your own open source all
the time, like I have done
with much pain over the years,
you can expect to see
some easier solutions
with a little bit less
friction and less of having
to manage them yourself.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I think we're
seeing a lot of people who
are super interested in like,
we don't want to solve a lot
of these problems that have
already been solved, right?
Like, let's lean
on the open source
community who have
built out these tools,
then kind of validated them,
and can help improve them.
And then for when we're
building our projects,
let us focus on
the actual problems
that we're trying to solve.
And whether it's a database,
or whether it's a framework,
or whether it's
something like Kubeflow,
let me get to what I want to do,
and use those cool open source
communities to drive the
hard work behind the tooling.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, let's
not reinvent the wheel.
Before you build
anything just check
to see if there's a project
that already does it
and leverage all
their hard work.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
speaking of making
open source a lot
easier, we just
saw James Ward, a developer
advocate at Google here,
push out a really cool button.
So Cloud Run is
something that people
have been talking
about just recently,
because it was
announced at Next.
And it really makes
it super, super
easy to take a
container, which I
think most people
are using by now,
or at least want to use by now.
And throw it up in Cloud
Run, and bam, it works.
And that's kind of
magical in and of itself.
But now James is like, by the
way, put this little button
in your GitHub Read Me.
And then now, people can
just click on that, and bam,
your code is now running in
Google Cloud Run for anybody
who wants to try it out.
So like now, when people
kind of go to a GitHub repo.
And they're like, oh, I
wonder what this looks like.
But instead of having to
download it, run it, build it,
set it up, and manually
deploy it all yourself,
you can just click a
little button-- click--
and then, bam, you've got
it running in your project.
So I think that's super cool.
MICHELLE CASBON: It is
amazing super cool and also
a little bit scary.
We're not necessarily
condoning clicking on random
run me buttons in GitHub repos.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That is a great point.
I mean, there's something
really cool about being
able to take some of
these open source projects
and just have them up and
running so you can test them,
but you should be aware
of what you're running.
You should take a look into the
code, at least understanding,
hey, this code could be doing
things, like most code does.
MICHELLE CASBON: But that's
the beauty of open source,
is that it's open
and you can check it,
perhaps before you click on
the button, maybe afterwards.
But that's also the
beauty of the cloud,
that if you run
something, at least
it's not on your local machine.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right,
I just kind of learned
about this ephemeral
cloud shell that spins up,
so everybody who has
a Google Cloud account
and gets a little
cloud shell, which
is like a nice little
environment where you can kind
of play with some
things, but also where
you can use the Google
Cloud tools, well,
when you click this
button, it also spins up
a ephemeral version of that.
So it's kind of like
an isolated sandbox,
again protecting you
from limiting out what
access that code might have.
And you can choose, I
believe, when it pops up,
you get that little
pop up that says,
hey, are you trusting
this application or not.
So it's no excuse not
to do your research.
I think that's a
very fair point.
But at the same time,
it's a super cool way
to kind of take out any
open source libraries
or quick GitHub repos
that you are like, oh, I
want to try this out, and make
that process so much easier.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, it is
a great way to take things out
for a test drive.
So the last cool thing
that I wanted to talk about
is some of my favorite code
labs from IO this week.
They involved
hardware accelerators.
So we'll take you through
how to use TPUs, which
are Tensor Processing Units.
They're Google's own version
of hardware accelerators.
They were designed
and built specifically
to run most efficiently
in Google data centers.
There's a series of four
labs that were created
by our colleague Martin Gurner.
You can run them
independently or in sequence.
They're a way to run through
some deep learning exercises.
And you don't have to know
anything about deep learning.
Martin is very well known
for doing deep learning
without a PhD series,
and these labs
are a great
introduction into that.
But they run on
code lab notebooks,
which give you all of the
hardware that you need.
They give you access
to everything.
And he gives you the code.
So he explains everything,
explains deep learning
concepts.
And he teaches you
how to access TPUs.
And you can watch them running.
And you can see what
they're good for.
There's some really
good examples.
So learning both about deep
learning and about TPUs
simultaneously,
which is generally
what people to be use TPUs for.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
I think that's very cool.
I mean, again, anything that
kind of lowers that barrier
to entry for machine
learning, which
is, right now, pretty high.
There's a lot of
very complex things.
And I think we're
seeing a lot of people
moving towards, well, how do I
make the most of this without,
like you said, having a PhD,
and kind of getting access
to cool things like
TPUs, which just make it
all that much faster.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
So that's it for our
cool things of the week.
Let's go into our main
contact and talk to Di.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: So
today, I think we
have a particularly interesting
interview, Di Dang design
advocate here at
Google, is here to join
us to talk about the
People Plus AI Guidebook.
OK, that was more
words than I expected.
Before we do that,
though, Di, do
you want to tell us a
little about yourself?
What do you do here at Google?
DI DANG: Yeah, sure,
so as you mentioned,
my title is design advocate.
And I've been a Google now
for a little under a year.
And what my role means,
what my North Star is,
it means that I go
out in the community,
I work with third party
partners on different emerging
technologies, such as
VRAR, machine learning
AI, conversation voice UI,
what are kind of technologies
they're considering to solve
their unique user problem.
And I help bridge their
gaps or pain points
when it comes to working
in these new technologies.
Because best practices
or design patterns
may be less established than
working with say pure web
and mobile by comparison.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: These
aren't just policies that
apply to working with Google.
They're policies that apply to
working with anything, right?
Like you just said, web, mobile,
AI, VR, all those things, those
are kind of guidelines
that aren't set by Google,
they're set by the world.
DI DANG: Yeah, they're
set by the world.
I'd say they're things that
we're figuring out and learning
as we go through it together.
So part of my
work, when it comes
to supporting the design
advocacy for these emerging
technologies, means working
closely with different product
area teams.
One key one for me
is working closely
with PAIR, stands for
People plus AI Research.
It's a team that's been
around for a couple of years
now, composed of cross
disciplinary roles, all
across Google, actually--
research scientists, engineers,
designers, UXers, and
so forth, who are all
dedicated to creating tools
and content around how can we
create human centered
AI, or how can we
create a partnerships that
are beneficial, ethical, fair,
inclusive for us as people.
MARK MANDEL: So you
said four words there
that I think probably hold a lot
of interesting stuff in there--
human centered AI.
DI DANG: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: What is that?
DI DANG: That is
a great question.
Let's kind of break
that down a little bit.
So the first question, AI--
so AI is a superset
of technologies
that include machine learning.
When I say human
centered AI, it means
how are we being
cognizant of our role
as product creators when it
comes to creating AI systems,
or AI driven products, or even
working on machine learning.
Because the truth of
it is that there's
a lot that we, as
designers and developers,
intentionally and
unintentionally influence
through all the phases
of machine learning,
whether that's in the
kind of training data
that we collect and label,
to how we actually build,
and train, and evaluate our
machine learning models,
to ultimately, the kind
of output and predictions
that come from these models.
We, as people, are affected
by those predictions,
by those results.
So human centered AI means how
can we make sure that we're not
just focused on the
technology of AI,
but we're asking
questions around
how it impacts us as people
at the end of the day.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I think we've
seen a little bit
coming up recently,
a greater understanding
of data bias.
And this is a big part of--
because obviously,
when you train
any form of machine
learning, or AI,
or whatever it is, it's based
on the data you give it.
And I think a lot of
people now are starting
to understand a little bit
more about what data bias is
and how easy it
is to kind of skew
what an AI system
will kind of generate.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
oh, yeah, absolutely.
So one of the things that we
talk about in the guidebook
is looking at rater UI.
So raters refer to
teams with individuals
who are often doing the
labeling of the training data
sets themselves.
And when we, say, like give
a simple task to a rater
to, say, label a set of images,
as is this a running shoe
or not a running shoe,
what are their connotations
around what that means?
So for instance,
if we showed them
a data set that
includes sneakers,
high heels, stilettos,
fancier sneakers, et cetera,
what are they
labeling accordingly
and what are they not.
That's kind of a
lower stakes example.
If I were to give a higher
stake example of, say, an image
data set of label who
identifies as a woman here,
or what is female.
That's where it gets
really complicated
around data bias and the
own cultural implications
that these raters may be
bringing to that task.
Because if you
say, for instance,
you have in that photo set an
image of like RuPaul, who's
a drag queen, or
Jonathan Van Ness,
from Queer Eye, individuals
who identify as male,
but may dress in more
androgynous ways or more
non-binary ways, if you
get that set of images
to a rater who's based
in another country,
another culture, what
kind of connotations
are they going to
be bringing to that.
And then that can skew
the kind of results
that you have in the end, if
you had like an image classifier
model around male and
female, for whatever reason.
MARK MANDEL: And just
a quick shout-out
as well, episode
114 of the podcast,
we did a machine learning
bias and fairness episode,
where we dig into this
a whole lot more too.
Not to say that we shouldn't
talk about it now of course.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Although
one point for talking about it
now is you mentioned a
couple of times a guidebook.
DI DANG: Yes.
Maybe we should have started
with that, seeing as how that's
one of the main reasons, yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think
it's interesting to talk
about the deep
stuff, but what is
the guidebook, what does it do?
DI DANG: Yeah, right.
So backing up a little bit,
the People Plus AI Guidebook,
we'll be releasing that
at I/O. I'm guessing
this will be live by then.
But we'll be launching at
I/O. And this is an effort
that teams across Google
have been developing
over the past year, chiefly
spearheaded by PAIR,
so again the People
Plus AI Research Team.
And essentially, it came
out of this question,
as different product
teams were wrestling
with what are the best
practices for designing
with AI, what design
patterns work, don't work?
How do you establish
trust with the user?
How do you convey the importance
of a confidence interval
and how the user should act
on that or not act on that?
All these different
questions that
arose around creating
AI products at Google,
kind of took a step
back and thought,
well, why not synthesize that
in a set of guidance or best
practices that we can share
with everyone, and that,
again, going back
to our earlier point
around these nascent
technologies, where
the patterns or
the best practices
are still in development.
How can we share this resource
out there, get feedback,
from everyone in
the world, who's
wrestling with
these same problems,
and eventually work towards
a healthier, more beneficial,
inclusive set of
design principles.
MARK MANDEL: So you solved it.
You solved it, it's fine now?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Once it's published.
MARK MANDEL: So it's done.
No [INAUDIBLE]
DI DANG: I wish.
It's a continual
work in progress.
And that's one of
the reasons why--
that's why I came here.
Because it's a project that
I believe very strongly in,
but it's not like we
just release it at that's
the end of that.
One of the things
that I'm working on
as a design advocate
is how can we
keep an open channel
of communication
between the PAIR team
that's developing
this content and the
rest of the world?
And what best
practices or patterns
may need to be localized
for certain cultures?
Are there specific
needs that we're seeing
in different communities?
Or are folks more interested
in health care, fintech,
or whatever guidance?
So that's why-- that's a
big reason why I'm here,
is not just to share the news
about this great resource
that developers and product
creators can utilize when it
comes to creating
AI driven products,
but also to hear from
everyone out there,
what's useful about the
guide book, what's not,
what's missing,
what's inaccurate,
and how can we make it
better to better serve you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So who's your
main target audience for this?
If you had to pick
the ideal person,
and you're like I wish
they would read this,
who are those people?
DI DANG: I'd say the
target audience is
anyone who's considering
working with AI driven products.
To put a finer point
on that, the guidebook
is written so that
it's very accessible
and that has a low
barrier to entry.
It's written primarily for
UXers and product managers,
because the truth of it is,
there aren't a lot of resources
out there around AI driven
product decisions for UXers
and PMs.
You have a lot of great
stuff like TensorFlow,
you have MLC from Google.
But those are more
engine developer focused.
And so we wanted to make
sure that we were offering
a variety of resources
that everyone could use,
that your cross-functional
product team could use,
to help answer these
questions together.
Another way of thinking
about the guidebook
is that it's not a crash
course in machine learning.
It's not intended to be
technical by any means.
But it's intended to
help you make decisions
around AI driven products.
MARK MANDEL: Correct
me if I'm wrong,
it sounds almost like
before you had this,
unless you were
technical, it was probably
very hard to understand what's
happening and that's a risk.
Like if you've got people
who are building products,
who don't really understand
how the technology works,
because the resources
don't exist.
Like, there's potential
for things to go wrong.
DI DANG: Yeah, oh,
yeah, absolutely.
And a lot of it's also because
the field of machine learning
has--
it's been around
for decades now.
And in the last
decade or so, it's
been continually
advanced by developers,
by folks who are more
engineering focused,
data scientists, et cetera.
And it's only recently that
product managers, UXers,
designers, are
realizing that we need
to be a part of these
conversations too,
so that we can make
decisions about the product
for our users, as a team.
After all, you have a
cross-functional team
that's composed of
PM, engine designer,
for any other
application or product,
why not also for machine
learning or AI driven products?
Because that's not something
that we see as much right now.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
it sounds like it'll
be changing over
time, especially
as you work with these
different people.
Ideally, anyone who's
hopefully using it
is also able to help
contribute towards it,
and say, these are the
thoughts that I have.
But for people
who don't know it,
this is a great way to get
started or at least start
to get some considerations.
What exactly is the guidebook?
Is it like a big O'Reilly book?
Are we talking about a couple
of pages, is it a white paper?
MARK MANDEL: Is it a story book.
Does it have lots of pictures?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That would be great.
DI DANG: I wish,
oh, man, maybe that
could be the next iteration.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Guidbook
V2, pop-up version.
DI DANG: If we keep getting
enough feedback on our feedback
form on the site
then surely I can
advocate for it to become
a pop-up story book.
MARK MANDEL: You
heard it here first.
Make sure you put in
there pop-up story
book for the next version.
DI DANG: And when I see
that feedback come in,
it's like that's how I know,
you listen to the GCP podcast.
Thank you for calling.
So the form factor,
it's a microsite.
And it's composed
of six chapters.
Let me see if I can rattle
off from memory right now.
The first chapter is user
needs and defining success.
And so that chapter helps
you answer earlier questions
around, should we AI
this, should we ML this?
What are good uses cases for AI?
What are not?
When would the user or
even your product team
benefit from using AI?
When would you not, et cetera?
The next is data
collection and evaluation.
So again, Mark, to
your earlier point
about how can we be cognizant
of implicit and explicit biases
that we may be bringing into
the collection, labeling,
evaluation of our data.
The next chapter
is mental models.
And that looks at what
is the mental model
that your user is bringing
to this application,
to this experience.
The general public, there's a
lot of wildly varying opinions
around what is AI, and
confusion with that, and robots,
or whatever other things.
So how can you better
understand the assumptions,
expectations that your user
is bringing to your product?
And then adjust the design or
the experience of your product
accordingly to match
those expectations.
The fourth chapter looks at
exploitability and trust.
Given that you may have
varying degrees of transparency
into the predictions that
your AI system is making,
how can you then convey
that level of transparency
to the user as a result?
What is useful to them?
What is not?
Also takes a look
at, as we mentioned
earlier, confidence levels,
in terms of sometimes
you need to be more transparent
with the user in terms
of the degree of confidence
they should be investing
in this application.
The next chapter looks
at feedback and controls.
So this is a key aspect to any
kind of application creation,
in terms of how can the
user tweak their settings?
How can they provide
feedback into the system,
to then train the model
to better suit their needs
and be better personalized
to their desires?
And then last chapter is
errors and graceful failure,
acknowledging the simple truth
that your model will fail.
There will be some
error at some point.
So how do you move the user
forward in spite of that?
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So how do people
use this guidebook?
Obviously, there's
a pop-up story
that they have to read,
but outside of that,
what should they
be doing with it?
DI DANG: So it's intended
as a reference guide.
So if you find that you
are struggling with issues
in any of those chapters,
you can pull it up,
can read through
certain sections
to answer any questions that
may be cropping up on your team.
In the guidebook, there are
also vignettes or mockups
of a fake app called Run.
These mockups, these
vignettes, capture
kind of patterns to aim
for or patterns to avoid.
And these are all
based on real insights
from product teams
across Google.
We've just generisized it for
the purposes of the guidebook.
You can take a look
at that and learn
from those example patterns.
And also, in the
guidebook there is
a worksheet that is attached
to every single chapter.
I know that makes it sound like
homework, a little less fun.
But the idea of the
worksheet-- it's
kind of a shorter
reference guide.
Includes a couple of checklists,
pointers, different questions
and exercises that you
can pose to your team,
to come to these
decisions together.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So you mentioned
a big part of your
role specifically
is going around
and communicating
with these people, getting their
feedback, and then, of course,
I hope folding that
back into the guidebook.
Who has really been
providing a lot of feedback?
And are people,
maybe, even using
this guidebook, or at least
concepts from this guidebook
without ever having
receiving it?
DI DANG: Well, we started
development on the guidebook
almost a full year ago.
And there's over 30
or 40 individuals
from different product
teams, across Alphabet,
across Google, who have
contributed their insights
or learnings to this.
And we've also been internally
testing the guidebook
with a few different
product teams across Google
in the last couple of months.
Like I said, we'll be
launching the guidebook
at I/O. We have a
40 minute session
talk dedicated to guidebook.
And to help bring
these concepts to life,
we'll be illustrating it through
a case study from the Google
Flights team.
So that's one of the key
teams that we've been
piloting this content with.
MARK MANDEL: So, I'm sure
that our listeners would
love to hear more about the
particular best practices that
have come out of the guide.
Is there maybe one or
two that are particularly
your favorites?
DI DANG: One of
the concepts that's
been most interesting to me,
and also, in sharing this
out with people both in
and outside of Google,
is looking at the
cost of optimizing
for precision or recall.
And this is something that
I'm still like-- each time
I talk about it, I
want to make sure I
get the terminology right.
Because I believe precision is
optimizing for false positives
and recall is optimizing
for false negatives,
or it's the other way around.
Each time, I feel like look--
I feel like I actually have
to sketch out the quadrants
and look at it to make
sure I'm getting it right.
But the short of it is that
we need to design the reward
function in a way that
optimizes for one or the other,
but we need to strike
the fine balance.
And I think an interesting
case study of this
is with the Google
Clips team, which
is it that that little wearable
camera that you could wear
on your shirt and that
would automatically
capture little
clips of your day,
and that you could then
sort through at the end.
And that way, it frees
you up to live your life.
You don't have to
be behind a lens.
But you have
something that's kind
of capturing these
special moments for you,
that later on, you can decide
to keep or dispense with.
And so an interesting
example of this concept
of optimizing for precision
or recall come to life
is with the Google Clips team.
They realized through the
process of user research
that actually, users didn't
want the camera technology
to optimize too
much for precision,
in terms of like what the camera
deemed as the most interesting
or the most unique as a photo.
Users prefer the
Google Clips camera
to optimize more
for recall, in terms
of like a wider
diversity of pictures,
even if it's something
that they don't
deem inherently interesting.
Because it gave them
a sense of control
to be able to sift through
their gallery and choose what
was actually special to them.
And in the end, they felt like
they could have greater trust
in the Google Clips
camera, because it allowed
them to define what was
actually special to them,
and make sure that no special
moment was being left out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, in that
case, there's such a low cost.
Because at the end
of the day, the user
basically says no, I
don't want this picture.
But in a more complex
scenario, that might have that,
there's got to be other balances
that take effect, right?
DI DANG: Yeah, so another
interesting case study to me
comes from the
Google Brain team.
When they built a
deep learning model
that could diagnose diabetic
retinopathy in patients.
And I can't remember why
now, but for some reason,
there's a variety of
confounding factors
that make it difficult
for physicians
who are highly trained and
experienced in this to diagnose
this.
And so, they actually found that
through the course of creating
this model, instead
of automating away
the human physician
diagnosis, the model,
working in tandem
with physicians,
could actually result in
higher accuracy of diagnosis
than either the model or
the physician by themselves.
And so that's an
interesting example to me
of how we think about
using AI for automation
or for augmenting the human
ability to do something,
like striking that fine
balance between both.
And that's something else that
we also cover in the user needs
and defining success chapter.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
like a really core component
of literally what you
call human centered AI.
Like you want to make sure that
it's an augmenting experience
in some way, shape, or form.
DI DANG: Yeah, exactly.
When we are making a decision--
if we, as product creators,
are making a decision
to automate away a task,
are we crystal clear that we're
meeting the ideal criteria
for automating it away?
So for instance,
it makes less sense
to automate a task that humans
find pleasurable, or enjoyable,
or even higher stakes,
it makes less sense
to automate away a task
that people can't agree on.
Because then if we can't
agree on the way to do a task,
that it means that we don't have
a clear set of criteria to then
train the model on.
There's also an interesting--
so kind of going deeper here--
Mark, to your point earlier.
There's an interesting question
around cultural bias or value
here, where some of the early
feedback that I've heard
is when we make
assumptions about tasks
that are onerous or
tedious to automate away,
that maybe that's a more
Western way of looking
at doing something.
We're in a greater
level of privilege
to be able to say, look,
actually I don't feel like--
I don't know-- opening my
mail, or scanning for spam,
or what have you.
But that's a
decision that we can
make due to our relative
level of privilege.
So what are the
implications of when we
do agree to automate something?
What does it say about
our value as a society?
Is that a decision
that we're making
or imposing on another culture
that we should be aware of?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I'm not sure
if anybody enjoys
opening junk mail, but--
DI DANG: Yeah, that was a more--
MARK MANDEL: Some people might.
Find your joy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It should be--
besides the
meditative experience
of finding out what
sparks joy in you,
does this guidebook
also address that,
like the cultural
segmentation almost,
that comes up from
some of these things.
Because it seems to me like it
would be really hard to make,
exactly what you said, a
blanket statement, that says,
look, everyone agrees
on no one wants to--
DI DANG: If it's tedious,
no one wants to do it.
Yeah, but there's monetary
value in doing certain tasks,
like those are
some people's jobs.
So being cognizant of that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, that's probably
the biggest kind of global
reaction to a lot of AI,
is that, hey, it's
stealing jobs.
And we just talked about
how augmentation is really
a little bit more
of the goal there.
What's the response
to those people
who are exactly saying that?
Like, hey--
DI DANG: Yeah, I
honestly don't know.
I don't have an--
I wish I had an answer for
you on that, but I don't know.
I think it's something
that we're all still
figuring out together.
And for me, in launching
this guidebook,
I want to make sure that
we are launching this
in events around the world.
That we're reaching out
to developer and design
communities around the world.
Because I think
it's very, very easy
to speak to, exclusively
West Coast audiences,
or even Western audiences.
And we need to understand,
from design and developer
communities as far away as like,
say Russia, Brazil, Slovakia,
et cetera, does this
resonate with you?
Does this capture how you think
about AI or machine learning?
And if not, what is missing?
What is inaccurate?
How does it need to grow in
order to better serve you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm assuming
the same thing applies again,
like socioeconomic, status,
gender, like a whole bunch
of different diversity
aspects that make up basically
society as a whole really kind
of affect how you're going
to make these AI models work.
DI DANG: Yeah, again, it's
not just about the technology.
It's about the impact the
technology has on us as people.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
is it possible to make
an unbiased model?
MARK MANDEL: Whoa.
DI DANG: I don't think so.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Welcome
to the deeper group, where
we go deep into questions.
DI DANG: I feel like
I need like a drink--
I feel like we all need
drinks for this right now.
Even the listeners right now.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: This might
be a beers conversation.
DI DANG: I don't think so.
I mean, speaking
personally here.
Bias is a natural part
of what makes us human.
But when I say natural, there's
not a value judgment there
of it being good
natural or bad natural.
It's something that we need to
be cognizant of and aware of.
And we're not just having
reflexive, knee jerk reactions.
This is a big part of my
overall design and product
philosophies, that
we need to be very
conscientious of the decisions
that we make as product
creators, because the
decisions we make around,
say, like
accessibility, or where
this particular element
of UI is located,
or even who our target audience
is, to the training data set
that we curate, all
of those decisions
then cascade and radiate
down to circumscribe
the set of decisions that
an end user is able to make.
Because of that, and
because we are all
human at the end of
the day, we will always
sustain some amount of bias
for or against something
or whatever.
And so it's on us to continually
be vigilant about that
and ask questions
about how can we
be more mindful about those
decisions we're making,
that then radiate
down to the end user.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: If only there
were some kind of guidebook
to help people decide.
MARK MANDEL: If only there was.
DI DANG: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
naturally segueing,
so if people want to learn
more, where can they go?
DI DANG: Yes, I'm very
glad that you asked.
We just finalized our URL.
So if people want to
check out the guidebook,
they can go to
Design.google/AI-guidebook.
You'll see the six
chapters there,
along with the worksheets
and interactive exercises
that kind of help you dig
into the material in a more
actionable way.
You also see across the
site a feedback button
that allows you to fill
out a form of any thoughts
or concerns that you
have, to share it with us,
so that we can continue
improving this document
and improving the set
of best practices.
The reality of it is
that the field of AI
is quickly advancing
and quickly changing.
And so should the way that
we design our products
as a result. And as
a result of that, so
should this set of
best practices and this
guidance itself.
And so, I want to hear from you.
We want to hear from you.
I'll also say that my
MDs are open on Twitter.
I'm at dqpdang.
Feel free to reach out any
time, if you feel the need to,
outside of the
feedback form itself.
And hopefully, I'll see you
at an event or something
otherwise.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I do
want to ask one question.
MARK MANDEL: Uh-oh.
DI DANG: Uh-oh.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's very interesting.
I think it's fascinating
that Google dedicates
a lot of resources, and
you said design advocacy,
developer advocacy is something
that Mark and I are in.
There's a lot of very cool
stuff that we get to do,
because we're
basically saying, this
is how we recommend working
with Google, or in your case,
with AI, and all these
different platforms.
Why is Google creating
this guidebook?
And why is Google
the one that people
are OK with creating
this guidebook?
DI DANG: Oh, well, there's
an assumption there
that people are OK with Google
creating this guidebook, right?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Here here's
a spoiler from my question.
They may not be.
DI DANG: Yeah, they may not be.
Yeah, I know, I know they
might be OK with that.
I know that Microsoft early
this year also recently released
a similar set of principles,
or best practices
around human centered AI.
We are not the first to do so.
And hopefully, we won't
be the last to do.
For me, I see this
as a conversation
that we're having
with people everywhere
who are considering or actively
working on AI driven products.
And this is just
another resource
that they can refer to.
And hopefully, they
find it useful.
Hopefully, they
find it relevant.
If they don't, then hopefully,
they let me know and let
us know, so we can
continue evolving it.
But to your question
about are people
OK with Google
creating it, I think
that's a very good question.
And we're about to find
out when we release.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Before we wrap up, though--
we are running out of time,
unfortunately.
Is there anything you want
to mention, or plug, or just
make sure that people know
about before we finish up?
DI DANG: Yes, as I
mentioned earlier,
the guidebook is developed
by the PAIR team.
And in addition
to the guidebook,
check out more tools,
content, and guidance,
and case studies from the
PAIR team at Google.AI/PAIR.
MARK MANDEL: We'll have
a link on the show notes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Personally, I'm
looking forward to that quadrant
as a page in the story book.
So I can kind of follow
it through and understand
exactly which one was
used, the false positives
and the false negatives.
DI DANG: Yeah, we
have a GIF on there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
but is it a pop-up book.
MARK MANDEL: It's not a pop up.
DI DANG: It's not a--
oh, what's a pop up GIF?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, it's a book,
I mean, like for the
actual guidebook.
DI DANG: OK, yeah,
that would work.
That would work really nicely.
I agree.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Di, thank you so much
for joining us on the podcast.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you, Mark.
MICHELLE CASBON: That
was a great interview.
Thank you, Mark, for
bringing Di onto the show.
And now, it's time for
our question of the week.
I have a question for you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK.
MICHELLE CASBON: Since you
just spent so much time
talking to Di, if
someone wanted to get
started with practical AI, how
would they go about doing that?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
that's an interesting point.
We were just talking
about in our cool things,
there's a lot of
machine learning
slash AI you can build at
the very, very kind of hands
on level, when you're getting
into the details of building
on machine learning models
and those sorts of things.
But at a much simpler
level, there's
some cool tools that Google
has that you can kind of just
get started with now.
I think one of the ones that
some people have been talking
me recently is Dialogflow.
There's been a lot of
movement about chat bots
and kind of creating these
customer experiences.
And you certainly don't want
to sit there and generate
a complete list of rules for
what a conversation might
have for people.
You don't want to say if they
say A, do this, B, do this.
And Dialogflow is a
very cool mix of AI
and the ability to
communicate with systems
and different APIs, to
kind of create a very,
very flexible, but
still fluid and easy
to understand AI communication.
So I think it's super cool
that we have Dialogflow.
And we've just recently
kind of pushed out
some code labs that
really easily step
through how do I actually
get started with it.
How do I build my
first chat bot?
How do I build these
different rules?
What do these
different things mean?
And then by the end of a
couple of different code labs,
you've got a functioning chat
bot that communicates out?
In these examples, it sets
up a calendar, invites,
and those sorts of things.
It's super, super cool to see.
And it's a great
way to get started
with what kind of AI starts.
So I think Priyanka put out
a lot of those code labs.
So we'll definitely include
things in the description.
I went through them last week.
And it was just awesome
to see how quickly I
went from knowing nothing,
which is a common state for me,
all the way up to kind of
having a working chat bot
that scheduled out
calendar invites.
And I'm like, oh, what kind of
cool things can I do with it?
And I think it plays really well
into the great conversation we
had with Di, and
kind of understanding
how do I build AI responsibly.
So I think for all the listeners
out there, give it a try.
And keep in mind all
the different facets
that you do have to consider
when building an AI system.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, there's a
few different approaches to AI.
You have Martin's code
labs that take you
through just raw, deep learning.
And then you have Di's approach,
which is very human centric,
and let's be conscious,
let's think about the models
that we're building, and
how they impact humans,
how they interact with humans.
And so, using the
Dialogflow example
is a great way to get sort
of both sides of the theory,
as well as practically, how
do you actually implement
that when humans are involved.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, and
no matter which kind of route
you go down, you're
going to need to consider
how you're building that.
I think Di did a great
job of explaining
some of the thought process.
And I think by the time this
episode airs that guidebook
will be available.
So it's definitely worth a read.
MICHELLE CASBON: Excellent,
I can't wait to see it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So now
that we've gone through that,
where is everyone
going to be, speaking
of when this episode airs?
I think it's going to
be during Google I/O.
MICHELLE CASBON: It
will be at Google I/O,
and we will be deeply
embedded in that event.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This feels so similar
to our Next conversation,
where we were like, oh,
yeah, what happened after Next?
Well, we all took
a nap for a while.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
I expect for Google I/O to be
just as intense for our team.
So it's a developer festival.
It's outdoors versus Next, which
was a lot of indoor events.
And this will be my
first Google I/O.
I've never actually
been to one before.
So I'm very excited.
And if you're there
this week, come visit me
in the code lab section.
So I'll be there every single
day, Tuesday, Wednesday,
and Thursday.
And if you're interested in
going to I/O next year, how
would you go about
getting a ticket?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
is an excellent question,
but I feel like you already know
the answer, because I do not.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Well, if you come
to visit me in the
code labs section,
the more code labs
you complete, we'll
be having a raffle
for passes for 2020.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Ooh, maybe
I should sit down and try out
some code labs, make
sure I get it next year.
MICHELLE CASBON: Maybe so.
So the labs will take you
about 30 to 45 minutes apiece.
And the more you
complete, the more entries
you get in the raffle.
But you could also, if you're
not in the Mountain View area,
you could also join
an I/O extended event.
Last year, we had 525 of these
in 100 different countries.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Holy moly.
MICHELLE CASBON: They're
all over the globe.
So either go to one
in your local area,
or if you're interested in
organizing one next year,
we're always looking for
people to host those.
And we'll help you
get it organized.
We have a ton of
resources for you.
And the idea behind
these I/O extended
events are that it's part
viewing party and then part
community building.
So you can set your own agenda.
You can have hackathons, code
labs, run the livestream,
and just bring your
community together.
So either find one, or if you
want to host one next year,
we'll have a link
to those resources
and get involved in
I/O. It should be great.
I'm very excited about it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
think that's very cool.
And it's also a really
cool way to kind of still
continue that
community tradition
without necessarily having to
be right here in the Bay Area.
So after I/O, I'm pretty sure
I'm going back into hibernation
mode until the next I/O.
[SNORING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes, I wish
I could take a nap after I/O,
but I will be prepping
for KubeCon Europe.
So I'll be giving
a workshop there.
And I'm putting
together that with a few
of our other colleagues.
There'll be quite a few
people from the Kubeflow team
over in Barcelona.
So if you are there on site,
please stop by and say hello.
Ping me on Twitter,
or reach out,
I'd love to meet you in person.
Or come to the workshop.
And we'll be providing
all the resources
that you need to run through
some Kubeflow tutorials.
We'll be showing off pipelines
and how you can run things
from within a notebook.
So very exciting.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
And lots of ways for people to
kind of interact with the teams
here who are building it.
But then, I'm sure there'll
be tons of people there as
well, who are kind of
like, look, we're using it,
this is how we use it.
And there's great stuff
to learn from that.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah I really
enjoyed KubeCon last year.
I also did a workshop
over in Seattle.
And this will be
another iteration
of that, the continuation with
all of the newest features.
And I really enjoyed
the people that I met,
the Kubeflow users, and
people who were just
learning it for the first time.
It was a really great
experience for me.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
Well, it sounds like
it will be a busy week,
and then followed up by
many more busy weeks.
So obviously, for anyone
who can come, great.
And if not, sounds
like there's great ways
to catch up otherwise.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
it'll be on video.
And the code lab will be public.
So we'll post a link to that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome, well
thanks everyone for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]